in our series on the new normal we'll
look at how this pandemic is
dramatically changing all of our
everyday lives those changes as you know
will affect the way we work the way we
learned socialize and travel of course
airlines are looking at the future of
flying as they struggle to make money
United plans to cut 30% of its
management staff in Southwest which has
never furloughed employees or declared
bankrupcy says 80% of its seats are
empty these days only on CBS this
morning Kris Van Cleave spoke to
Southwest CEO about the changes they are
making is it even safe to fly yes
Southwest Airlines CEO Gary Kelly is
fighting to save the jobs of more than
60,000 employees to do it he'll need
Americans to believe it is safe to fly
during the corona virus pandemic we are
urging the TSA to begin temperature
scans as part of the screening process
at the checkpoints by Monday virtually
all US airlines will require passengers
and crew to wear masks how do you
enforce mask wearing on a plane if we
can tell people in advance that they
should expect that we're requiring them
to wear a mask and I think the vast
majority of people understand why and
will absolutely comply we don't want to
be the police airlines are adding
Plexiglas at check-in and ticket
counters you'll see them at TSA
checkpoints as well carriers are
continuing to enhance cleaning on both
planes and at airports Southwest is
using electrostatic foggers to disinfect
planes they can kill bacteria and virus
on surfaces for up to 30 days and Kelly
says their aircraft utilize hospital
grade air filters the airplane can be
hospital-grade cleaned until you put
people on it who may or may not be
healthy and that's where the risk comes
in right it is and that that's why I
think leading up to that wash your hands
don't come to the airport if you're sick
let's do temperature screening
ultimately obviously the solution is to
have testing therapeutics a vaccine if
social distancing even possible on an
airplane well I think that's why the
multi-layered approach is important
we'll have wipes on the airplane that
each customer can take requiring masks
on
airplane are important because you won't
necessarily all be 6 feet apart would
removing the middle seat make a
difference but we're not gonna block the
seat we're not going to take the seats
out but we won't book the number of
passengers that would demand that we use
the middle seats can you make money
flying at a max two-thirds full our
break-even load factor was somewhere in
the 60 to 70 percent range can we do
that indefinitely
no Southwest has grounded about 400
planes and cut capacity by up to 70% as
passenger traffic plummeted but Kelly
sees this as temporary I do think that
things will get back to normal but not
until we defeat this pandemic and it
could be a long way to normal Kelly
thinks it'll take up to five years for
business travelers to get back to their
2019 level I asked him if he would be
surprised if a US airline went out of
business during the downturn he said
some failures may be inevitable and his
focus was on saving Southwest something
he thinks he can do without further
government assistance but Anthony
there's so many open questions here
about how long this lasts Anthony yeah
so many so many indeed Chris and and
most importantly what's it gonna take to
convince passengers to get back on
planes thank you very much Chris